Luke I think I'm gonna I'm gonna have to
ask you to be a little bit more
sensitive to we have a refugee from
Canada
I'm going back on something he didn't
say sorry yeah let me back why are you
coming back are you crazy I got my
family in Canada
go to Mexico we'll see what happens in
the future there Canada's going off the
rails now if anybody has yeah Trudeau's
most going has been no it's getting it's
getting worse Trudeau put out a tweet
that says uh you know when uh Health
Canada approves the new vaccine we're
ready to go with it for eight kids five
to eleven yeah so he's appealing to his
own organization that's under Federal
control effectively but to approve a
vaccine that he's already purchased for
the use that he intends on getting
approval for and tell me that's not a
fan but I mean can you travel
domestically without a vaccine passport
in Canada as I think it's as of November
yeah 12 years old and up if you're not
fully vaccinated cannot take a plane or
train uh yeah so that's crazy so uh is
where you live known uh oh yeah no I'm
in Montreal everybody knows that I just
I just ran
so if you want to go to Toronto for
instance if you want to hop on a train I
don't know that it's in effect yet but
it's coming if it's not already in
effect you'll have to show your vaccine
passport to hop on a train what's uh
it's Province right what province is
Quebec Ontario I'm in Quebec then
there's Ontario then there's if you
enter into Ontario there's a border do
they got do they check you not anymore
they did over the summer which I found
uh enraging politically constitutionally
enraging into provincial travel which is
a constitutional right under our
constitution
um they asked for papers and they made
us register they made us go back to
Quebec go online register to go to New
Brunswick for a portion of our road trip
that's insane I mean they brought up
blockades literally these orange uh
little freaking uh armed guards yeah
yeah no no they brought these like um
what are they called
um the orange things that they follow at
water that stands that uh what bollards
cones cones no no Jersey barriers yes
they brought in whole bunch of water
Jersey barriers in Australia Banning
people from even crossing the street
because there was an imaginary line
between two different states you
um you managed to to escape I imagine
you must have crawled through a tunnel
somewhere actually it was the it was the
U.S border they were very nice the three
guys I mean the whole team was very nice
they look sympathetic and understanding
to the purpose of my travels
um but yeah I mean I had to show
everything to get across for
non-essential work as of November 8th
borders are going to be open the land
border for non-essential but that means
you're gonna have to show proof of
vaccination I think it's 12 or 13 and up
which basically means you know if you're
not vaccinated you're not traveling when
you said it violations institution you
you put it in quotes I have I I'm not
trying to besmirch the Canadian
Constitution but now I have I've come to
grips with the fact that it seems now
more like a recommendation for the
government
the Queen's role in that like is it a
recommendation everything it's like you
can they were rights guaranteed by the
charter it's section one these are the
rights guaranteed by the charter they
can only be infringed in as much as is
justifiable in a free and Democratic
Society and now it seems that in a free
Democratic Society they can lock you up
in a government quarantine hotel for
three days and make you pay two thousand
dollars for it if you want to leave the
country where there have been
allegations of security guards doing
unspeakable things to women and there's
many ongoing criminal prosecutions right
now of of those guards who are at these
hotels literally opening up the door
when women are by themselves can't have
locks the doors can't have laws yeah the
doors can't have locks and security
guards have assaulted many women in many
of these situations there's been a few
incidents but the quarantine hotels are
no longer in force now for now
um but it's it's nuts the rights that we
thought we had under guaranteed under
the Constitution have all been
systematically violated and now the
ultimate irony is that in Quebec English
quebecers are complaining that their
linguistic rights are being violated by
Francois ago and I said like you guys
just let him lock you in your house
after eight o'clock five months you
think he cares about your language do
you remember spaghetti
which one is that that was when in
Montreal there was an Italian restaurant
that was serving spaghetti and it just
said spaghetti and the language police
came and said why isn't it in French and
they were like because it's spaghetti
and this is an illustration I don't know
about that case but I had clients who
had canned goods coming in from outside
of Quebec that had the ounce
abbreviation in English they had to put
on a sticker that had the ounce
abbreviation in French that's the
language police that's they called them
a language police it's uh office in
their uh enforcers the enforcers of a
French language it's a unique Province
so so so so this is what this is funny
because you brought up that people are
angry they're they're linguistic rights
are being infringed is is uh what's the
guy's name Francois the premier of of
Lego
l-e-g-a-l-u-l-t a-l-u legal the girl I
can't speak French but uh so what is he
doing he's trying to you know make he's
trying to keep French as like yeah he's
trying to revamp an old law from 1977
called Bill 101 which created certain
linguistic protections for the French
language which meant and you know French
had to be netmo predominant on public
signage clearly predominant uh ended
applying to businesses of 50 so he's far
right Ultra nationalist it's a it's a
it's an ironic thing I don't know how
these measurements work anymore but
right bottom line this bill 96 now it's
going to enhance language laws it's
going to cap the amount of French
Canadians French quebecers that can
study English in post-secondary
education so this this is how you
protect the language it's by crippling
your own population yeah but if the
Anglo is complaining about it now I say
you reap what you sow and you should
have been out there on the street doing
Viva on the streets complaining about
the curfew for five months but you
weren't because you thought it made you
feel safe and now what's the
justification what the government
doesn't have a right to to do this well
and he's invoking the notwithstanding
Clause of the of the Constitution which
says you have guarantee you have rights
and freedoms that are guaranteed by the
charter except we get to violate them if
we specifically say in the law that we
are violating those rights and if you
don't like it I start look it up it's
called the notwithstanding Clause
um close in French and it basically says
if the government specifically says
they're violating your specific rights
certain rights are not able to be
violated they can invoke this Clause the
law can last no longer than five years
or a shorter specified time the idea
being if you don't like a totalitarian
government you'll vote the mode next
election but it's it's ridiculous
basically CBC says it it's the uh not
attending Clause section 33 gives
provincial legislature of parliament the
ability through the passage of law to
override certain portions of the charter
for a five-year term it's great it's
great so imagine if that's like in the
US they'd be like we're passing a law
that will violate your second amendment
rights because the Constitution allows
us to violate your rights well we kind
of have over the last two years
suspended the Constitution pretty much
everywhere I mean we've created in the
de facto emergency exception of the
Constitution which we've never had it's
what level and that's used to rise to
power in Germany sure sure because I
think we got to be a little bit more
fair than that it was it was the famous
quote from Patrick Henry when he said
Give me liberty or give me death unless
there's a pandemic or a flu going around
or a flu or a flu or or if we go to war
in a foreign country and Ben Franklin
Thomas Jefferson were like oh absolutely
I mean we we must get entangled in four
and we must get stuck in foreign
entanglements environmental crisis right
well I mean especially I mean this was
our constitution was formed when we had
what seven smallpox epidemics during
that time period yeah I mean so it
wasn't like they were unfamiliar with
the risk they were intimately familiar
with it and decided we should not
forfeit Liberty that's that's actually a
good point when people are like George
Washington mandated vaccines my response
is like for his conscripts yeah exactly
were forced to join the military sure
and uh interestingly they still
guaranteed our rights in a constitution
having dealt with a smallpox epidemic
and didn't include that as an option
going forward but she could have he
could have included a military exception
he did not so the founders knew exactly
what they were doing and we've just
abandoned it over the last two years
this is this has been my biggest
learning curve in doing the live streams
of Robert The Genius of the Constitution
the U.S Constitution the Bill of Rights
I mean it's it's fantastic and it took
foresight and it's a good understanding
when people first started saying Canada
has no freedom of speech they started
telling me this you know back with
Jordan Peterson and compelled speech
like no you guys are wrong we have
freedom of speech to hear then Mike Ward
got sentenced to got fined 43 000 for
making fun of a handicapped kid Jeremy
Gabriel then I was like you guys might
be right and now now it's it's on
steroids yeah it's crazy up there man
and it's cold yeah it's cool but the
cold is beautiful it's it's a it's a dry
cold as we say it's not it's not it's
not moist I'm surprised we don't have
more radicalized Canadians because you
have like harsh conditions and
oppressive government that's like a
recipe for people to lose their minds
well the People's Party what triple the
vote people's probably triple the vote
nearly a million Canadians who voted of
The 16 million who voted is 800 and some
odd thousand voted for the PPC and then
Robert you saw this like after the
election
people were asking why would Justin
Trudeau call an election during a
pandemic it's it's a you know Health
crisis how could you call an election
they went after and are still going
after the PPC for a post-election party
that they had where they got the
Saskatchewan police to put like the
FBI's most wanted list to post 11
pictures of people who attended an
after-party of the election night and
asked for anonymous tips to identify the
11th January 6th what the heck yeah
it was an Insurrection yeah an
Insurrection election party they they
got the Saskatchewan police Saskatoon I
think to actually tweet it out help us
identify these 11 individuals it does
you're going to find fascinating is that
in France they Riot for everything but
in Canada not nearly as much like what
how does it how does it happen you know
because when you look at here's the way
often explain it with uh with England
right you know the the English they come
over they colonize parts of the new
world and we inherit a lot from these
original settlers people who are willing
to risk everything to come to a new
world risk death to build something with
no guarantees because they wanted
Freedom they wanted you know for a
variety of reasons religious freedom or
otherwise
the French
came over here as well
but Canada is very very different from
you know like France revolts you know
the the yellow jackets when they tried
raising petrol prices the yellow vests
they're going through 15 weeks of
protest right now against the vax
mandates with yeah but so why why
doesn't Canada inherit a lot of a lot of
that I don't know and Robert and I have
discussed it like even within Canada you
would think Quebec would be revolting
against this more than perhaps the rest
of Canada crickets and and it's I think
look when you see people sitting outside
on a park bench double mask reading a
book the media has had its impact now
and people believe they need these
measures in order to feel safe and be
safe and I they they've passed that
point of no return well Canadians always
say sorry all the time so I think that
has a big big thing to do with it but
then we got Tom McDonald and some other
some other good candidates who don't say
sorry Seth Rogen's Canadian and he's a
dick do you think it has something to do
with the Commonwealth and the queen
because Australia and Canada are getting
rocked right now by this we're not we're
not at Australia levels I just think
it's like you get to a point where you
feel that there's nothing you can do to
step it back so you either are you
either are convinced it's necessary or
you're just beaten into passiveness
where you there's nothing you can do
like can the queen just say hey your
Constitution is gone now the queen as
far as I understand has that's what they
say symbolic that's what they say but
then she can also like dispel she can
get rid of the Prime Minister if you
want I don't I don't think so but uh
subject to error nobody likes being
right wrong on the internet okay
otherwise you don't know is a Canadian
lawyer and if you want the correct
answer just assert one of them to be
true and you'll get inundated I get
different information from different
people about the Queen's Authority and
the Commonwealth my understanding is she
has it's symbolic it's purely symbolic
and her face on our money is also purely
symbolic it's not how it works in my
understanding but I know people say that
but no we have our parliamentary system
we make our laws and I don't think the
queen has any do they own a lot of real
estate in Canada like in London I was
shocked at how much royal families
because Megan couldn't uh couldn't come
to she didn't come to Canada so I'm not
sure that they do interesting thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time